In order to interact with our robots moving in the environment, we need to
capture the input from the user and react to it in proper fashion. For Grids,
we have two primary forms of input. Number one is keyboard, where we use the w,
a, s, d keys to actually allow our robot to move around and get into all sorts
of conky trouble. In order to shoot, we allow mouse input for your player so
you can actually see that as I move the mouse, the little mouse cursor moves.
We don't actually rotate the upper body of the robot until you actually fire
though. So you can see that as the mouse moves around, my projectiles are of
course following it in suit. This allows the player to move as well as shoot at
the same time. Now for those of you out there that do most of your gaming or
programming on a laptop, you probably don't have an external mouse. We've also
allowed the ability so that you can play Grids as well. And for that, rather
than actually aiming your robot to shoot at things using the mouse we allow you
to use the arrow keys. So that pressing in the specific direction will shoot in
that direction as well. And, of course, combinations of keys will allow you to
shoot in diagonals.